We're going to make a
bit of an island favorite,
and that's the mojito.
You don't want to tear
the hell out of the mint.
We want to agitate it
a bit, so just give it
a quick slap over
the back of your hand
because what we want to
have is that first bouquet
as you go to take a sip.
I'm Lynnette Marrero.
And I'm Ryan Chetiyawardana.
I think I messed up
my own name there.
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
To me, cocktails are magic, and
there's something about them
that really helps bring together
people in a wonderful way.
[CORK POPS]
I've learned how to find
expression through liquid arts,
so I hope you get
extremely creative.
The foundation for
all good cocktails
comes from knowing
classic cocktails.
Whiskey sour.
Martini.
The Bloody Mary.
Margarita.
The Old Fashioned.
Understanding the
balance of those drinks
is extremely important.
I want to show how
great cocktails can
fit into your everyday life.
[RATTLING ICE CUBES]
It's hard not to be inspired
by a charcuterie plate.
One of my favorite pairings
is having a smoky whiskey
with blue cheese.
That's a great
flavor combination.
Bitters are the
seasoning of your drink.
They're there to kind of bridge
all the other flavors together,
and it really acts
as this kind of base
in the background of the drink.
Really simple, but
super delicious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Knowing how to incorporate
eggs into a drink safely
and deliciously is
really important.
You have to think about
it in bakery terms.
You're using
something that is raw
that is getting
cooked by the citrus.
That's what creates
that silky texture.
It's not about
having crazy equipment.
Ultimately, you can
make things using
jam jars or teapots or
paintbrushes and chopsticks
to stir your drinks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
No matter what
your background is,
I guarantee we will learn
some things together.
And there's
something really fun
about getting your
friends together and just
throwing this all into the mix.
Cocktails and bars
have always been
a place where people come
together to share ideas,
and so we are thrilled
to share our ideas,
our philosophies, our sense
of community with you.
Cheers.
Always a pleasure.
I'm Ryan Chetiyawardana.
I am Lynnette Marrero.
And this is our MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]